what have you learned about men from
doing this kind of work
all men are paying for [ __ ] in one way
shape and reform you're gonna pay for it
whether it's taking a [ __ ] to dinner or
taking you know buying or whatever
[ __ ] want
things they have desires and you want us
all right princess yes princess where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally uh carnation washington
where's that
it's near seattle it's like 45 minutes
east of seattle real small town
and tell me about your family growing up
um
my parents are still married actually
they've been married for 41 years
they live in the house that i was born
in still
had i stayed i would have graduated from
high school with the same kids i went to
kindergarten with
i played softball
for 12 years with the same nine girls
real small town
how was your childhood
um
from the outside looking in it was it
was nice like we had a house like my
parents weren't my mom worked for
medtronic well for back then it was
physio control
eli lilly um
and
she retired from there but my dad was a
locksmith they always worked and stuff
had bought their own house but like my
dad's a
dick like my dad was abusive
emotionally and physically
um
there's not a lot of my childhood that i
actually remember
and when i suggested to my mom that i
get hypnotized she was like oh no julia
don't do that so
i guess that
they'd had an episode with my sister
getting hypnotized but um
there's not there's there's some
lost time there that i
i was thinking because like getting
ready to do this um to talk to you i had
been just like racking my brain trying
to think about different things that i
would maybe want to talk about or share
with you and uh
i was just kind of tripping off like how
much i don't remember about my childhood
how old were you when you left home
um the first time like 13 i think
um
i went back and forth a lot
it was hard like um
i feel like i made any excuses for the
men in my life my whole life like
oh and i'm sick to my stomach i've only
talked to this one other time about this
ever one of the time and i was with my
mom but
the other day
and um because my daughter ran away from
home but um
the word molested to me is such an is
such an ugly term and i don't feel like
it was motivation but i know that it was
like i know that you're not going to be
14 and 15 years old and a grown ass 35
year old man should not be
sexually trying to
like approach you at all especially like
people at your church
or people who you know your grandparents
friends who live next door like it
it was it's
i just always received the attention of
men that i didn't really ask for
unsolicited attention
and with my dad being such a [ __ ]
douche i i
just wanted any man to love me i don't
know
yeah it's like the one the one
leads to another
yeah it seems and then it carries on
your whole life yeah
and that so
eventually you get into sex work
yeah yeah yeah most definitely um
it was that uh
i was
grown by the time it happened though i
had
um
lost my son when he was nine months old
what yeah when i was 20 he drowned at my
sister's house um
yeah joey pulled himself into
the tub after my niece got out
but after that i just kind of fell off
like um
i left washington forever
came down to california
first time i came down here was with wes
and monica but
when i came down here and stayed i came
down here with macbon
he's my turnout folks
and it's crazy because the night before
i met him
i'd actually turn my first date
all by myself
but
from the very beginning
i was crafty
i'm not one of them girls who who was
like laid on her back and just let
tricks do whatever they want to me
and i won't say that ever like outright
robbed anybody though
like i'm not gonna pull a gun on anybody
but if you know you leave and nothing
happens then that's you know between
us but
i've definitely had some crazy
situations with uh lots of tricks but
the first time that i ever turned at
eight
he gave me like 400 bucks and uh
got me a room and all this [ __ ] and i
told him that i couldn't even do it i
was just
totally
[ __ ] up with it
and i was but i wasn't it was a role
definitely roll
and um
the next day i'm at my mid bone
and he brought me down here
i was like 21 22.
pretty old actually for to get turned on
the game
most yeah young girls
and um
it's funny because
they've always called me a bit from the
very beginning they're like oh you met
you event and like
i'm like okay
i let them call me what they want and i
convinced them till they were convinced
and i convinced myself
but
uh
it's crazy
i could
trick stories go on for days but um
what's your craziest trick story
craziest trick or craziest trick story
like i had a trick who used to give me
like 800 to wear stockings and talk
about stepping on bugs just talking on
just talking like stepping on bugs like
have you ever stepped on a roach before
he'd ask me
and i'd be like well yeah of course he's
like well how did it feel
how do you think it would feel if you
didn't have any socks on like between
your toes and stuff like was it more
like a pop or a crunch and i'm like
really that's what you want to talk
about while i wear these stockings
that's what we're doing and he's like
yeah yeah yeah
and he worked for uh i probably
shouldn't say but i'm going to anyways
he worked for spacex he used to fly his
airplane to work every day from catalina
and
yeah he was weirdo wanted to talk about
spiders and
stuff like that well i wore stockings
what have you learned about men from
doing this kind of work
um
what haven't i learned about men like
i'm pretty i swear i should write a book
uh
all men are tricks not all men are
victims
that's definitely what i've learned it's
okay to be a trick it's not okay to be a
victim
you know you know the trick is gonna all
men are paying for [ __ ] in one way
shape and reform you're gonna pay for it
whether it's taking a [ __ ] to dinner or
taking you know buying or whatever
[ __ ] want
things they have desires and you want us
so
you don't listen to the new music it's
ridiculous
prostitution's become so popular it's
not even cool anymore
seriously there's no money in it like
there was like
do you do you regret getting into it
absolutely absolutely like
i would i don't like the word regret
because i really i'm not trying i mean i
if you want to talk about regrets i this
could go forever but like i try to not
have that
over my heart like i've made some bad
decisions and stuff like that but they
were still my decisions and i stopped to
live with them so they were
they were bad decisions they weren't
regrets because
i don't know everything happened for a
reason i guess
you were with your pen for a long time
no actually my turnout folks i was not
with for a long time my turnout folks he
very quickly um i saw that he was a
terrorist
and like i tried to leave him and he
knocked me unconscious and shaved my
head balls so this was a gang member
pimp oh yeah i don't [ __ ] with nothing
but gang members um i've i um that's it
i don't know how that happened i'm from
a really small town like whoa i'm like
we had like three people that we were
black in my whole town like i'm just
being honest
and like for me i am all my children are
mixed like
except for my oldest and and
i don't know i
i black men a black man the first time i
ever felt attractive i was by black man
i was teased my whole life growing up
like i i didn't
i always
teased i said i didn't always look like
this but
i didn't always look like this and um
so i was teased a lot and and i got
called thick by a black man on a
greyhound one time and i was like i was
ready to fight because i thought he was
calling me fat and he was like whoa no
think is good think it's good
and um
i don't know i just like i guess i like
said foreign men generally speaking not
just black men foreign men
but um
so my turnout folks yeah after that
whole incident with the kidnapping and
then shaving my head bald
actually [ __ ] with one other pimp
after him and that was only i don't know
how that happened because
i'm an [ __ ]
just by nature and after
my turnout folks shaved my head bald i
did the unthinkable and went renegade on
fig
because i just had to clown like you
can't phase me
you can't do it i got rejects tattooed
over his name on my ankle because i had
his name on my ankle and
i hit fig
and
my turnout folks he told the story about
or not my transforms but
the next folks i [ __ ] with
he uh said he hit the corner with his
partner in the car and his partner was
like that's a bald head he's like i'm
flipping you turn on that [ __ ] he's
like man that's a bald headed [ __ ]
right there and mp was like that's a
million dollar [ __ ] right there
and turn around and pick me up bald head
and all but that didn't last long either
i don't
i was raised in abusive home and i have
a hard time with with men who put their
hands on women
so
but you're attracted to
african-american gang members well right
but
i was with an african-american gang
member for
15 years and
the only time he ever laid a hand on me
was when he was under the influence of
drugs and it was only one time like i'm
not making excuses for him it didn't
make it okay and i didn't tolerate it
then but
the guy who i spent 15 like
years on off and on really with like
he's a good man really
we all make bad choices and stuff like
that but we just have to
deal with the choices we make i don't
know like i could have probably made
better choices
i don't even know anything else though
like i don't even know what it's like
like
i don't remember ever learning how
to like go to work every day and like
have a regular job nobody ever taught me
nothing like that even growing up at
home
i don't i don't know how my sister's a
doctor i don't know how she made it like
i swear to god i don't your sister's a
doctor yeah my sister's a doctor she was
a nurse she got married right out of
high school to a pastor her pastor
actually her youth pastor uh-huh
and it was like real
traumatizing it was it's i it broke my
heart to see like to look at my sister's
wedding pictures because like my mom's
whole face his nose is red cheeks her
puffy eyes are swollen because he's like
19 years older than her or something
like that but like
i get it because chucky was 19 years
older than me and
um
we didn't really have a dad like that
like not one that we that loved us how
much do you think that
played a role in where you're at today
or where your life took you know where
it led
uh probably a big part
i would definitely say a big part
i just all everyone was my dad to be
proud of me
clearly he's not now
right
what kind of what kind of things have
you learned by
doing this kind of work
about men mainly probably where i'm
leading um men always telling themselves
i don't know um
they're narcissistic
they're easier to please and everybody
thinks
and all anybody really wants is just
somebody to just
make them feel like they're wanted
just like anybody they want
companionship more than they want so a
lot of the times
that used to be my gig
that used to be my gig because
you know like i said i smoke crack for
10 or 25 years and
i take a full pull and get to performing
and they would i i had
tricks who would like alfie alfie was
one of my favorites alfie's ass his
[ __ ] ass every time he do it
every single time too and it wouldn't
matter he did the atm card like he'd
give it to me and i
i call it ass to mouth because that's
what i found i feel like i'm doing these
tricks when they give me their atm card
oh i'm sorry
and uh they give you the atm yeah yeah
and it's just like now i'm [ __ ] you
in the ass and give it a seat in the
mouth because you should not have done
that yeah i got the code i got the
everything because they like the abuse i
guess a lot of men do i had to check one
time i've heard this a lot who let me
rob him three times in one day like
literally the first time i met him was
like on the blade
and we went to my room and my best
friend knocked on the door i was like oh
you got to go and he had already given
me the money and i was like i'll hit you
back later and he came back to my room
and he was like yeah i have more money
and i was like okay cool come on
and then something else happened i was
like you gotta go and i got him again
and then he called me and was like hey
can you come to me i have and he gave me
like it was like 300 more dollars than
it had originally been already how much
did you take him for the i got him like
600 that day
but i literally went to his house after
that and brought my homie with me
and like we bought that he went up in
the room with me and he gave me but a
lot of guys seem to be into
getting taken by by girls yeah it's
weird
but alfie was the best like alfie give
me like because he's had a lot of money
off he had a lot of money he had me
driving an audi a8 and everything like
what do you think that's all about
um
i don't know maybe mommy issues
something
i don't know maybe they know they ain't
[ __ ]
i don't have like the reason that i had
to uh
because i [ __ ] hate tricks man i
don't have no respect for him like
i don't they just
they're so
gross and and so like
i mean not all of them let's not get
misconstrued like there are some tricks
who are attractive and there are some
tricks who are like
good decent people but like overall
they're douchebags and like any time any
trick is trying to save a hoe or save a
[ __ ] he's not really trying to save a
whole or save it but she's trying to get
some in-house [ __ ] that he thinks he
doesn't have to pay for no more and that
he can control and do all that other
extra [ __ ] i
i left my daddy for doing that when i
was 13.
i left my last daddy
very quickly too like i'm i'm very much
a free spirit
and that's crazy too because
i've recently got like
into a relationship where i cut
everything off now that's kind of what
happened so you're out of the game now
yeah and now i'm out of the game
are you in love
yeah
so you believe in love absolutely
absolutely are you kidding me there's no
better feeling than being in love it's a
shitty feeling but yeah i would agree
but but most of the girls that work the
track i don't think
i mean they have a form of love that's
very different yeah and a square is love
yeah and and i i i because like if you
were in love with a girl and she was
having sex with 17 other guys that right
and it's funny because like chuck you
wouldn't call that love chucky and i we
were together 15 years and like he knew
what i did obviously but like it was
more like a partnership like chucky
would help me get these [ __ ] like
and you actually probably have heard
about um chuck before sorry because our
friend that's the french he talks about
right we were together forever and she
told me when she said i had to [ __ ] with
chuck because you were with him for so
long i had to know what kept you at uh
your attention for so long i had to know
and i was like yeah whatever [ __ ] but
um
chuck like
i don't know
he played the boyfriend role on so many
different occasions where he's
beat knocking on the door as soon as you
know the
the tricks giving me the money we had
swerve ones we when the uh next tell us
first came out the chirp chirps
uh i would turn and be like swerve one
chirp jerk and that meant that he knew
exactly where i was going
and then chuck and i like he we i don't
know like he was
that was my dude like i don't know i
couldn't the reason i couldn't [ __ ] with
the pimp is because they have too many
[ __ ] and when a whole like when i go
to work when i when i hit the blade
that's my job
i don't pick these [ __ ] i think
i trust didn't believe that if i had my
choice
i would not let any of them touch me
like i'm the girl that physically
cringes when like tricks touch me that's
why i could never like
because i mean
i was
like i had
the
more than one offer to like by very rich
men to old men to
let them take care of me
but for me love is just genuine i don't
know and i can't pretend to love
somebody for some bread like if you want
to [ __ ]
that's cool we can do that but like all
that getting to know me and all that no
i don't do none of that with none of my
tricks
it always goes left like
always i [ __ ] hate them but uh
i've had tricks try to rob me i've been
raped it's all happened it doesn't take
long for it to happen
it's part of the game
you just get you just get back at it
yeah unfortunately
unfortunately i was right before i was
never in the game though i was raped in
my hometown when i was young really yeah
buy some pizzas
yeah before you started doing this
before i ever got into sex work and then
i actually had my when i lost my
virginity it was a real bad experience
for me too i wasn't raped but it was
like it was my best friend's brother and
then he lied and it just it started
rumors in school for me and it just
ruined my whole high school career
it was bad and i'm sure
those events and maybe being molested as
a child yeah led you know yeah
my mom told me that we're pretty sure
that i got molested
when my sister because i told you my
sister got hypnotized so
and uh i i became aware of my body
sexually i remember being aware of my
body being able to give me pleasure at a
very young age very young age
disturbingly young
age so
but that's why my mom suggested i don't
get hypnotized
she was like oh no don't do that and i
was like whoa
like damn i really wonder what do what
do you not want me let's keep the truth
in the closet right it's better there
well it's just like yeah that's funny
because
um
my daughter
recently ran away and with that like
all the windows that they've been the
glass house that they've been showing me
and telling me about with my kids
because my sister has my kids it's a
rough story but
my sister has my kids and uh they always
try to make it seem some type of way
where everything's just perfect and the
kids are so happy and
and then my 16 year old hit me on
facebook
not so much she ran away
not only does she run away she doesn't
want to live there she doesn't want to
be with them she doesn't want them to
adopt her she doesn't want their last
name they've been pressing me for years
since chuck died because i lost chuck
suddenly after uh
let me tell you i've lost like everybody
in my life my best friend my
husband my child like
i buried a lot of people
and
the person that you choose for 15 years
of your life
that should hit something different like
your partner you have to wake up every
day and choose to [ __ ] with that person
you have to wake up every day and choose
to like especially in the game
choose to hustle through and just get
through it and
it's different it takes a special type
of woman to do it it took that
like literally took the air out of me
and and his family did me dirty
but i got you sidetracked me i'm saying
that
helen's like a job
so like if i have a boyfriend or i have
my dude like chuck
that's not i don't you can't consider
that cheating i have not picked any of
them like if when you go to work and you
get paid for your job
are you cheating on me because your boss
pays you for your time
because a lot of times that's all i get
paid for is my time
but
that's why i and i'd be hard like if
unless she's another [ __ ] who wants to
get some bread
then you don't need to [ __ ] with her i
mean you can go [ __ ] on whoever you want
to clearly
but
don't bring that drama home unless she's
got some money but
i'm in a monogamous relationship right
now it's kind of interesting
do you believe in monogamy not at all
i don't think it's realistic i believe
in it but i don't think it's realistic
do you think we're supposed to yeah
that's what i'm asking yeah i think that
um
it's easier for women to be monogamous
than it is for men to be monogamous
but i don't at the same time i think
it's every it's a choice for people
everybody
um
but i don't think it's realistic yeah i
don't
[ __ ] happens should prostitution be
legalized
i want to say yes because
it should be
but at the same time like
i wouldn't want this for any of these
like i
if i can just save one girl
for making the choices that i make
because this life is not for nobody
like i was
i don't know if it's because i got
another game so late or what but like
i don't like another man touching me
different than touching me and that's
probably why it's probably easier for me
to talk about monogamy like being
realistic
i just learned in a term the other day
it said i didn't know what demisexual
meant
and somebody had posted the other day
and it's somebody who
cannot become sexually attracted to
someone without having a deep emotional
connection
i never knew that did you know that
what's it called it's demisexual
you can't become attract you can't know
that you can't become sexually attracted
to someone unless there's a
an emotional connection like a deep
emotional connection well that's most
people in here not necessarily then if
that's the case then why are all these
men picking up okay you're [ __ ] on
them you're like but there's sexual
attraction like some people that's easy
to have sexual attraction with no love
yeah there's a lot of guys right whereas
a demisexual somebody who can't
have sexual attraction unless there's an
emotional connection exactly which is
probably why it was so easy for me to
just
it's probably a lot of women and most
men yeah like i just for a lot of men i
yeah right
sex is not equate love to me like sex is
like in in a relationship with me sex is
like the lowest of my priorities
like literally i mean of course it's
important but
i'd rather have somebody who
i can spend time with than [ __ ] on like
there's certain parts of my body i don't
like touch now just because they've been
groped too many times
like
i had to stop or i was going to hurt
somebody and it wasn't me
how does doing this kind of work effect
how did it affect you emotionally
how does it affect me because it's still
effective yeah it still did yeah i was
going to be happy it's going to always
affect me and um
i wouldn't i don't i don't know how to
answer that to be honest with you i
don't i don't know the long term
other than like
it's hard for me to
find a a like um
a rhythm
like i don't know how people get up
every day and go to work how the [ __ ] do
they do that i don't know how to do that
i swear to god the thought just like how
do people like is it scary for you to
like get out of the game and now you i
don't even know what to do with myself i
swear to god and like budgeting and all
that what is that you want me to do what
i get bread every day oh i don't get
bread every day anymore
so now i'm broke and i'm struggling
and they still call and it's really hard
like have to block a lot of numbers
like my trick that bailed me out of my
first health case still calls my phone
like
it's been a long time that's 20
something years
20 years 20 years
and you still got my phone and i bailed
it's like on that bail and everything
like what's up
and your new guy was somebody you met
somebody that i met like he was and it's
crazy because
he was married for 17 years and his wife
literally was like don't come home
i'm pregnant by somebody else and i
don't want to be with you anymore
and change the locks on them and they
got like six kids together and
i got 17 years is a long time to be
married
you tried to commit suicide like three
times before i met him was it was he a
client no
he was a friend of a friend i met him at
these they have these tap houses now
yeah and i met him in a tap and he was
in the corner with his hoodie on and his
sunglasses
and like in the corner just but he's
like he's tongue in and so he's just
this big ass
tongue and he's knocking everything out
like it doesn't even matter and i was
like who is that
and somebody introduced me but then it
was like everywhere i went he was right
there
and he was saying on the same [ __ ] like
birth how are you here i don't even know
you knew these people and it was like
whatever i'm gone and then like i'd pop
up somewhere else and be like dude how'd
you beat me here
and uh
it's been a struggle like
um i guess i'm somebody who likes to fix
people i think i can fix people
my babies um
are all gone and so
they're here live but they just got
taken from me or i just
really let them go
to my family my family made it real easy
how many kids
i've given birth to six babies yeah five
living
is it the drugs that
kind of
made that happen
or the lifestyle
a combination um
[Music]
fear a lot of it's fear
people have made it easy for me to just
give up on a lot of [ __ ] in my life you
know
like
i had my when you know my sister tried
for
for a long time to have a baby
had like 14 miscarriages and
i gave her a son
and then i had my daughter and i was in
county on my way to prison when i had
her
so my sister came and got her
from from when i had her in the county
jail
by the time i came home she was calling
my sister mom
and like in your head you tell yourself
well they're better off
you know
[Music]
they're with each other
they're with my sister they're with my
family they get to see my mom you know
and like i said my sister's a doctor so
my kids have a really good life or
whatever they just make it easy
and then they took my daughter
thanks to my sister and the man who i
did three years in the penitentiary for
um
and then my own actions of course
are you the black sheep
of your family oh most definitely
by far is that a dna thing or is it
something that happened to you that
didn't happen to your sisters
well we all have different dads
i don't know if it's a dna thing or not
but my my mom got married three times
before she married my dad
um but my parents like talk about the
same nuns from elementary school they
went to elementary school together when
you close their senior yearbook their
faces literally touch literally
um
but mom got married twice before she
married my dad she's married to like
three years to her first husband for
like six to her next or something like
that she married my dad for 41 years
you know bobbing candy she became candy
cane when she married my dad
because she always say her name's
candace but everybody always called her
candy as soon as she married my dad now
everybody calls her candace
but everybody gives her candy cane
treats yeah whenever christmas comes
around she has candy cane everything
so
yeah
what's your biggest regret
my babies
my babies
that's every woman's yeah who's lost
but you know i still have time
my daughter you know she's been hitting
me up like i said
that glass house shattered recently and
and like it's really crazy to me because
like two weeks after chuck died my
sister sent me an email
asking me to um
sign over my parental rights because i
still have my parental rights to laura
she's the only kid the only kid i still
have them too but
because they wanted to change her last
name from chuck's last name to their
last name
because laura at 10 years old felt
insecure about her last name being
different
i thought it strange to myself at the
time like what 10 year old even thinks
about something like that i mean
honestly unless somebody else is telling
her to think like that
and they press me and press me and i
keep telling them oh yeah send the
papers and the papers and then pay me
and everything to do it they think that
they can get me with their money
but to me
i know chuck
and i would never disrespect him
by just willingly giving away his
daughter so that they can change her
last name she's the only legacy he has
and he like chucky was
he was my best friend
i wasn't even physically attracted to
chuck when i met chuck
i happened to be like
in the streets
hoeing
renegading
and then here was just chuck like
somebody introduced me to him and he was
just like when he was there with chuck
when i needed a chuck in my life
he's so dope
i just started smoking dope
at least craig and uh
the first time that man and i had sex i
laid there and hit the pipe watching the
portal in the corner of the movie
it was in the i'll never forget it it
was in the corner above the closet at
the value in and uh
i just laid there to the point where he
told me he's like look if that's gonna
be what our sex life is like
i can't [ __ ] with you
and
you know like i said a little while ago
sex to me is like the least motivating
factor for me
but this is how i learned
to perform and
um
it's hard to make me count like
nobody i've had one person ever in my
entire life make me come from
intercourse ever
ever
i don't know if it's because i was maybe
because i was molested when i was young
they [ __ ] me up but like
it's hard to make me have an orgasm and
i don't have orgasms from inner course
period like i think the girls be lying
when they say that they have orgasms for
intercourse they're like yeah right
and not that it doesn't feel good most
time but like
i think a lot of women are built
differently
yeah i just think that maybe like my
[ __ ] got [ __ ] up or something
who knows who knows but i've never
been able to have orgasms from
intercourse and so
i think i can tell you damn near the
longitude and latitude of the two
orgasms that i had that i did not fake
while i was with that man and that man
will tell you right if he was here right
now that he could
tell when i'm having an orgasm
okay honey
all fake
but
i i didn't like i love
there was a point where i was very much
in love with chuck like you couldn't
tell me i thought he was the sexiest man
on earth
but it wasn't because i thought he was
attractive it was like chuck really
loved me
and like
i fell in love with chuck because how
chuck loved me
he was like he was really my best friend
we really had a lot of fun together
i remember there was a time when
he wouldn't play nothing but that
[ __ ] song by day by beyonce
dangerously in love we had a range rover
land rover at the time and if i tell you
that
it's a beautiful song and i love that it
the words and all that [ __ ] but oh my
god he played that song one more time
like it was on a rapey in the rover all
the time dangerously in love like come
on chuck everybody knows that we're in
love okay let it go
um
but i'm glad you know it's i'm glad i
had that person
in my life through this because i
probably would be a lot more jaded
and um
adverse to uh
finding love then then i am
i love being in love who doesn't
i mean the heartbreak [ __ ] sucks the
fight everybody fights and [ __ ] a lot of
people are afraid of it though yeah but
i'd rather
like if i died tomorrow
i know that i've really been in love and
i know that i've really been loved
and so that's okay like
i feel bad for people who who
and it's crazy because like my true love
is am i like the person who makes my
heart even now
is it the person i'm with
but it's not chuck either
but like in the middle of like chuck
i'm like 10 years in a check
i met this guy named bear and it was
like if i tell you that for 10 years i
don't care who you were you could have
been kobe bryant i would have been like
what i'm with chuck
and then like it was like i ran into
this guy bear
and
i was like chuck i know i know somebody
named chuck there's who's check like
but unfortunately like it kind of like
[ __ ] chuck up
like because bear he hi too
and him and i proceeded to like
terrorize the world
like
i have
i had more fun with bear in that like
eight months than i've had with anybody
in my life
and like
he ended up getting 51 years
you like bad
boys but
like he got five years on the actual
case in 41 years in enhancements 46
years in enhancements
so hopefully he's coming home soon
but like
that's one thing that like if i don't
quest that bear loved me for sure chucky
did too
but for chuckie it was like different
like for like i said like chucky was
like a steadfast like solid like
i could have robbed chuck
and called him 10 minutes later be like
chuck
just well we just took all the money i
just took from you chuck and he'd be
like [ __ ] i'm gonna go kill him and
like
he always had my back and like
but bear there was passion like it was
it was a roller coaster it was so much
fun
i miss him so much to this day still we
i talk to him when i can and i send him
money and stuff when i can
but
yeah he's solid you know bears a real
gangster and that's my real gangster you
like gangsters i am gangsta
you are gangster yeah
i i
hanging out in englewood it happened i
eventually
started gang banging
happens i got a big old ck on all that
[ __ ] on my leg
but princess what do you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
if you ever think you shouldn't do it
don't do it
that's a good one like if you even like
think like whoa should i then don't
and always go with your guts i don't
care what it is
and i don't know like my
love yourself
really
you can't do nothing
if you don't have that like you have to
love yourself or you can love anybody
else even
nothing's going to get off the ground
nothing's going to happen nothing at all
all right princess thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you
very interesting thanks
you